翻訳: Mizuho WATANABE
校正: Kazunori Akashi
皆さん こんにちは
山田 もと子 と申します
今日は 皆さんに
「福祉は おもしろい！」
というテーマで お話をさせていただきます
ぜひ 私の話が 終わった後に
「あ 福祉っておもしろいんだなぁ」 って
思っていただけたら 嬉しいです
皆さん 福祉と聞いて
どんなイメージを お持ちですか？
今ですと やはり 介護ですとか
ボランティアという言葉を
浮かべる方も いらっしゃると思いますし
障害者福祉 高齢者福祉 児童福祉
なんていうのもあります
私は 27歳で ―
今 私 テレビディレクターという
仕事をしているんですけども
27歳で 福祉の現場で
取材をするようになるまで
まったく 福祉とは接点のない
生活をしていました
普通 そういう福祉分野の取材をするっていう
ディレクターさんや 記者さんがいたとしたら
例えば 大学時代に
ちょっと 勉強していました とか
あるいは 高校時代にボランティアを
経験しましたっていう方がいるんですけれども
私は いっさい 何もないところから
27歳で 取材をするようになりました
じゃ なぜそれまで接点がなかったんだろう？
接点がないばかりか 私 ―
避けていた 自分がいたんですね
で それはなぜかを ちょっと考えてみました
それは 小学校時代に 答えがありました
私が通った小学校には
養護学級が 「あった」 ようなんですね
あったようだ というのは
実は その６年間で
その 障害がある子供たちと一緒に
学んだり 遊んだり 運動会に参加したり
っていう 記憶が 一切ないんです
しかも 教室に戻ったときに 担任の先生が
たとえば 宿題を忘れたり
ちょっと いたずらをする子が いたりしたら
「こら お前ら 養護学級やるぞ！」
まぁ 今思えば ちょっとひどいんじゃない？
っていう 言葉なんですが
当時は まだ 教師ですら
そうした言葉を 特別な差別意識を持たずして
口にしていた 時代でした
子どもだった私たちは
そういった言葉を すとーんと飲み込んで
どどーんと あっという間に大きな心の壁 ―
偏見の壁というのを
築いてしまっていたんですね
なので 私は 27歳まで
むしろ その壁を避けるように歩いてきました
それが 27歳のときに 転機が訪れます
1995年 私は NHK札幌放送局で
リポーターとして働いて１年が経っていました
ある日の夕方 それは 突然訪れます
横山やすしによく似た アナウンス統括が
夕方やってきた
「おい 山田 ちょっと来い」
なんか 飲み会の誘いかなぁ
なんて思って 行きますとですね
「おい お前 ちょっと
福祉リポーターやってくれや」
その瞬間ですね
出会いは
ちょっと 時代の背景を説明させていただくと
これ 65歳以上の方が 人口に占める割合
高齢化率のグラフなんですけれども
この1995年で すでに14.6％です
下の解説を 見ていただくと分かるとおり
７％以上で さらに伸びてる状態が高齢化社会
そして 14％になった段階で
すでに 高齢社会 と呼ばれるんです
もう95年の段階で超えているんです 日本は
ちなみに 今年は ―
これ去年の数字なので推定になるんですけども
26.8％ だと
なので すでに高齢化という
途中ではあるといっても
高齢社会 ―
立派な 高齢社会になっています
決して それまで福祉というものは
国が施すものだと ―
それが 2000年に 介護保険が
実施されるのに合わせて
もうすでに 準備が始まっていて
それぞれの権利が 地域 ―
地方に 移譲されていったんですね
じゃあ その地方 それぞれで行われる
最新の福祉情報を
リポートとして 上げてもらおうとして
NHK厚生文化事業団が作ったのが
福祉リポーター制度です
私は その矢に 当たったわけです
しかし その当時の私
さっき お話ししたとおり
福祉なんて まったく縁のない人生で
福祉？ ボランティア？
意味の違いも 分からない
困った私は なんとかして
この 北海道社会福祉協議会という
なんとなーく 福祉に詳しそうな団体が
あることを 探し出しました
そして 代表番号に 電話をかけました
「あの すいません」
今だったら こうですけどね
（笑）
「すいません 私はですね
あのー これから福祉の取材を
しなきゃいけないんですけれども
どこに 何をしに行ったらいいでしょうか？」
っていう 今にして思えば無知丸出しの
ほんっとに 恥ずかしい電話をかけました
しかし そこに 神様がいたんです
その 神様が
「山田さん 机の前にいて
何を取材しようかを探すなんて
それ 無理だから」
「今週末に ちょっとおもしろい
介護講座があるから 受けに来な」
もう 藁にもすがる思いという
まさに そういう思いで
そして 私は その講座を 受けに行きました
そのときに 講師としていらしてたのが
この 三好春樹さんです
三好春樹さん この当時すでに
カリスマ理学療法士として
全国を 飛び回ってらっしゃいました
理学療法士というのは 皆さんご存知のとおり
リハビリを 専門に扱う
フィジカルな部分の お医者さんのことです
三好さん かなり アグレッシブな方で
すでに このとき
「チューブはずし学会」「オムツはずし学会」
なんていうのを やってらっしゃいました
なぜかというと 実は当時 介護という言葉は
まだ とっても新しい分野だったんですね
実は それまでは 看護 ―
医療の延長で 行われていました
医療というのは
治ることを前提に 施されるもので
ですから その 病院の施設というのは
治療を施すのに 都合がいいように
できてるんですね
例えば ベッドです
ベッドは 今でこそ 高さが変わります
しかし その当時のベッドは 高いままだった
そうすると そこに
足腰弱ったお年寄りが 乗せられてしまうと
おっかなくて 降りれない
しかも トイレに行きたくても
間に合わないんです
そして 粗相をしてしまって
オムツを つけられてしまう
人間 排泄が うまく回らなくなると
食欲もなくなります
そして 経管栄養 ― チューブが入ります
そうして たくさんのお年寄りが
あっという間に 寝たきりになっていきました
その 問題を 解決するのは 何か？
三好さんがやったのは
ベッドの脚を切る ということです
ベッドの脚を 切ることで
お年寄りは 自由に 歩き回れるようになる
それだけで 寝たきりを 防ぐことができる
三好さんの 講座というのは
フィジカルなお医者さんだって ありますけど
実は 実技も たくさんありまして
それは 例えば 看護師さんたちが
いかに 少ない力で
大きなおじいさんたちの 寝返りを打たせるか
あるいは 車イスからベッドに移乗するときに
腰を使って 持ち上げちゃって
その当時 腰痛で 働けなくなる看護師さんが
続出してたんですね
それを 太ももの筋肉を使って
持ち上げて 移乗するっていう
そういう 実技をメインにした
講座でも あったわけですね
だからそこで たくさん 目の前で寝たきりに
なるお年寄りを見ている 看護師さんたちが
こぞって たくさん 参加されていました
その 皆さんに 三好さんが 掛けた言葉
私 忘れられません
「皆さん 日頃でも 大変な仕事の中で
貴重な このお休みを使って
この 自分の講座を
受けに来てくださってるでしょう？
そして 決して安くはない受講料を
自腹で切って いらっしゃってる
そんな皆さん きっと
職場で浮いているでしょう？」
（笑）
そうすると 会場から
どっと 笑いが起きたんです
あぁ そういう方多いんだなぁって思いました
「中には 三好の講座なんか 受けちゃいかん
って言っている 病院もあるのも
僕は 知っています」
「でも 皆さん 安心してください」
「皆さんが浮いているのではなく
周りが沈んでいるだけですから」
（笑）
なるほど
三好さんの講座を 私が 福祉の取材の
玄関口で 受けることができた
「福祉は倫理ではなく論理
そして本質に基づくものである」
そして 命を守るものが 医療なのであれば
福祉は 生活を 守るものなのです
もし皆さんが 70［代］80［代］になって
何かしらの病気 あるいは 障害を得て
あっさり 今 自分としての生活を
諦められますか？
何か それまでとは違う方法であったとしても
やはり 寝て 食べて
そして 自分の好きな場所に出掛け
そして よしんば 働く
そういうことを やっぱり
続けたいと 思いますよね？
それを サポートするのが
福祉 というものなんです
こう聞きますと 福祉はおもしろいというより
なんか すごーいことなように
思ってこられたかと 思うんですが
私が その三好さんの講座のおかげで
「福祉というものは
毎日の生活の延長線上にあるものだ」
それが分かって もうホントに
福祉の取材に のめり込みました
まさに 放送局の名刺というのは
パスポート代わりです
どこに行っても いろんなお話を 伺えました
それは それぞれの実体験に基づいた
切実な声だったり
もっと こうすれば
社会は良くなるよ というお話だったり
そうした のめり込んだ ネタを元にですね
私は ひとつの転機 ―
1999年に NHKから uhbという
北海道文化放送という
フジテレビ系列の 民放に移ったのを機に
番組提案を しました
NHKではできない こんな番組をやりたい―
こんな番組でした
それが こちら
『ユニバーサルデザインリポーター
石井ちゃんとゆく！』
という 番組です
当時 福祉のテレビ番組というと
障害や病気を越えて がんばってるっていう
ちょっと 感動ドキュメンタリー的な
内容のものか
あるいは 差別や偏見を糾弾して
改善を訴えかけるような 社会派のニュースの
どちらかしかない そんな時代に
ちょっと これ 異色の番組でした
この 石井さんという
とってもユニークなキャラクターの
楽しいリポーターさんの 性格を借りてですね
彼女と一緒に 番組を作りました
楽しく 分かりやすく そして 一口サイズ
CMに挟まれた 番組と番組の間に
２分という 短い時間で 放送し続けました
例えば どんな番組だったか
ちょっと ご紹介しましょうね
「車イス駐車場に止めてはいけない理由」
皆さん 明確に 説明することが
できるでしょうか？
これね 「止めちゃいけないのは
分かってますよね？」
っていう 倫理に訴えかけちゃったら
どーんと 壁にぶち当たります
やっぱり 自分もちょっと 具合悪いときに
入口に近い車イス駐車場 とっても魅力です
雨降ってる日に 遠くしか空いてなかったら
ちょっと 豆腐１丁 買う間だったら
いいかって 思っちゃいます
でも こういうふうに
説明したら どうでしょうか？
さぁ 石井ちゃん
一般の 駐車場の幅を 計っております
2.5mありました
そして 車イス駐車場を計ると
3.5mです
その差 １m
この幅 何が違うのか ご存知ですか？
実は というところで ―
車イスドライバーさんが 実際に
車から車イスに 乗り移るところを
映像で 見せます
このように ドアを全開にしないと
乗り降りすることが できないんですよ
じゃあ もし一般の駐車場に ―
結局 ここが使われていて
一般の駐車場に 止めるしかなかった場合
どうなるかというと
隣のドライバーさんが
戻ってくるのを 待つしかなかったり
あるいは 他の人に 自分の車を
出してもらうしか 方法が ないわけです
実際に 私の友人で
車イスの人が 病院に行ったときに
１時間 真冬［に］
外で待ってたことが あったそうです
これを聞いたら
やっぱ ちょっと 雨の日であっても
ここは 止めちゃいけないなって
なんか思いませんか？
「包み隠さない情報」
これも 私は障害がある 当事者の皆さんから
教わった 説明の方法なんです
「それはまるで
はしごを外されるようなものなんだよ」
そう 教わりました
そして 日本UD話
石井さんは とっても芝居上手な方でして
今回は おばあちゃんになってもらったりして
昔がたり風に ご紹介をしたんですが
これは 実はちょっと 東北で あった実話を
昔がたり風に 演出してあります
ある村に 古ーい村役場が あったとさ
玄関には階段 そして 扉は重かった
村人たちは 玄関を まず 自動にしてほしい
自動ドアにしてほしい
そして スロープを付けてほしい と
言いましたけれども
村はたいそう貧乏で することができなかった
しかし 村役場に働くある若い男の思い付きで
20分 30分ぐらいで
見事解決してしまいました
さぁ 皆さん これ どうしたと思いますか？
答えは 簡単なんです
廊下向きだった机を 窓向きに変えたんです
すると 役場にやってくる人たちの姿が
よーく 見えるようになりました
足の悪いおばあちゃん 来たなーと思ったら
職員の人が出てって 扉を開けます
自動扉
そして 手を引きながら
「今日は暑いね おじいちゃん
膝のあれ［具合］ どう？」
って 会話をしながら 上がったりします
ベビーカーの人が来ても そう
これ すごく 心地のいいサービスですよね
実は この後 実話として
予算が下りて 「さぁ 工事しますよ」 って
言ったそうなんですが
村の人たち 「いやもういいよ別に
手を 貸してくれるから」
人間のサービスの方が 非常に心地がいい
まぁ もちろん こういったサービスを
どの規模の町でも できるかというと
それは そこが当てはまる町と
当てはまらない町が あると思います
しかし 障害がある友人が 教えてくれたのは
健常者の皆さんは 100％ ―
100点を 目指しすぎないかい？って
要するに 全部工事をして フラットにする
スロープにする 自動扉にする ―
それが 福祉で
それが 障害のある人のためのものだ
100点を 目指さなきゃいけない って
思いすぎてないかい？
でもね マンパワーで こうやってまかなう
65点が あったって いいんだよ
要は 福祉というのは
人を置き去りにしないことなんだと学びました
この方法は 大評判となって っていう
オチが ここでつきます
こうした機転も 立派なUDじゃ？
ということで
ちょっとこの ユニバーサルデザインについて
ご説明したいんですが
それまで バリアフリーという言葉が
一般的でした
バリアフリー という言葉は
階段であったり 段差であったり
急な坂道だったりですね
そうしたものを 困難に感じる人のために
なくしましょう フリーにしましょうという
要は 段差があることを前提としている考え方
それに対して
ユニバーサルデザインというのは
これから建てる建物の その施設に対して
どんな方たちが 使うだろう
というのを 先に考えるんです
で 車イスの方がいる
段差で 荷物を運ぶ人も いるだろう
ベビーカーの方もいるだろう としたときに
じゃあ そこの玄関の形はフラットがいいのか
階段の横に スロープを付けるのが
いいのか というのを検討して
誰もが使える形に
最初から作っておく というのが
ユニバーサルデザイン という考え方です
だから 国民総当事者
なので この番組のテーマを
ユニバーサルデザインにしました
最後です
「どっちが先？」 という放送回
これ 最終回から２回目の
放送だったんですけれども
実は 今 この 車イスの 佐藤くんが
雪道に はまってしまって
動けなくなっている
そんなところに
石井さんが 通り掛かるんですが
まぁ 日本人 なかなか 「どうしました？
お手伝いしましょうか？」 と
声を 掛けづらいですね
これ 日本人独特の 倫理観もあると思います
なんか 差し出がましいんじゃないだろうか
いやいや お世話になって
申し訳ないんじゃないか
そういう お互いの気持ちが
こう おもんぱかるあまりに
沈黙の時間が 長くなったりとか ―
じゃあ どっちが先に
SOSを 先に言ったらいいのか
石井からでしょうか？
それとも 佐藤くんからでしょうか？
その答えは ―
「あなたから！」
気づいたあなたから とりあえず
声掛けちゃってください
そして もし
「あ 結構です」って断られたら
「あ それじゃあ お気をつけて」 と
爽やかに 言ったらいい
それで いいんです
こんな感じで いろんな障害当事者の方たちに
お話を伺いながら
13年間で 635本
番組を作らせていただきました
本当に 感謝しかありません
惜しまれてですね
ちょっと 自分で言っちゃいますけれども
（笑）
2014年3月 去年ですね
３月に この番組は 終了しました
本当に たくさんの皆さんに
ご協力いただきました
さぁ 「福祉はおもしろい！」
という話に 戻しましょう
どうしても 福祉 といいますと
皆さん 何か 体にご不自由がある方
そして 障害がある方に対して
何か して差し上げること
というふうに 思っていませんか？
そして 皆さんの心の中に
もしかして 私が子供のとき
小学校のときに 作ってしまったのと
同じ壁が あるのかもしれません
もし その壁が あるなって思ったら
その壁 ―
いきなり壊してっていうふうには言いません
痛いですから
でも それがもし
レンガで出来た壁なのだとしたら
そのレンガの １ブロックだけ
スポっと抜いて
ちょっと その先を
ぜひ のぞいてみてください
そうすると その先には
70［代］ 80［代］になって自分が ―
自分の生活を 諦めたくないって思う
自分と同じように
もう そのパイオニアとして
経験してくださってる 当事者の皆さんが
生活してる姿が 見えてきます
その 生活する姿が 見えてきたら
これから 私たちが
突入していくであろう 高齢社会の
ヒントであったり 設計図が
そこにも 見えてくるはずです
そうして 皆さんの心から
壁が なくなっていったときに
町からも また 壁は
なくなっていくんじゃないでしょうか
皆さんで その みんなの知を ―
知の宝庫である 福祉を使って
ユニバーサルデザインの
町づくりを していきませんか？
壁を越えて
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）